my name is alina  i'm 20 years old  and i live in novosibirsk russia  [Music]  i like makeup i like body art  i think it helps me to express myself to  show my personality  make myself shine i don't know  [Music]  i'm currently a student  and i study chinese language and asian  politics  now  look at this rainstorm i'm gonna go play  in it  i first met stephen on a language  learning app  i was like whoo he's very handsome  he was very kind and  he joked around a lot  i immediately felt a strong connection  i love steven and i can't wait to  reunite with him  my entire life and right now i'm living  at home with my mother and grandmother  in three days i'm leaving for turkey to  be with steven and i know that my  family  are worried  i had to take one year off my university  and i am leaving my home behind  my mom met stephen when we were in  prague only for one week  for  [Music]  you